ich möchte mich bei allen für die
unglaubliche unterstützung bedanken
ich gehe ins ottfried krankenhaus mir
geht es gut aber wir wollen sichergehen
der first lady geht es gut vielen dank
ich werde das niemals vergessen
es dauert 17 stunden bis sich us
präsident donald trump nach seinem
positiven corona test am zweiten oktober
zum ersten mal in einer videobotschaft
zu wort meldet kurz darauf verlässt er
das weiße haus und wird mit milden
symptomen leichtem husten und
erschöpfungserscheinungen wie es aus
seinem umfeld heißt ins krankenhaus
geflogen
noch in der nacht versammeln sich seine
unterstützer vor den toren und beten für
eine schnelle genesung
wenn lazarus von den toten auferstanden
ist woran ich fest glaube dann können
wir unserem präsidenten durch die kraft
des gebets den willen gottes und durch
diese wunderbaren ikonen helfen
funkstille kein tweet von donald trump
während die ärzte den präsidenten
untersuchen herrscht unsicherheit über
seinen zustand gerüchte kochen hoch ob
er wirklich erkrankt ist spekulationen
ob er nur ablenken will von seinen
steuertricks oder seiner weigerung sich
von radikalen milizen zu distanzieren
ich mache mir sorgen wie er die dinge
interpretieren wird dass er sich erholt
und dann sagt sie das ist gar nicht so
schlimm und dass die menschen es noch
weniger ernst nehmen
am tag darauf tritt sein ärzteteam vor
die kameras und versucht zu beruhigen
dem präsidenten gehe es schon deutlich
besser heute morgen fühlt sich der
präsident sehr gut in washington bringt
donald trumps infektion 30 tage vor den
wahlen alles durcheinander
corona ist eine tückische krankheit mit
unterschiedlichsten verläufe was
passiert sollte der präsident doch
ernsthaft erkranken was wären die
konsequenzen für die stabilität des
landes und für die bereits laufenden
wahlen
manche patienten die noch älter sind als
der präsident können entweder milde
symptome haben oder gar keine
manche haben starke symptome brauchen
aber kein beatmungsgerät bei anderen
kann es schlimmer werden nach so wenigen
tagen ist es nicht möglich vorherzusagen
wie es sich entwickelt man muss von tag
zu tag schauen
eine der wichtigsten fragen ist was sind
die folgen für die wahl verändert diese
situation die entscheidung von wählern
und werden sie überhaupt wählen gehen
niemand kann jetzt ernsthaft sagen was
die konsequenzen für die wahlen sind
weil niemand weiß wie ernsthaft die
erkrankung von präsident trump sein wird
so etwas hat es noch nie gegeben nur
einen monat vor den wahlen entfernt am
sonntag will präsident trump den
widersprüchlichen aussagen über seinen
gesundheitszustand ein zeichen der
stärke entgegensetzen und macht
begleitet vom secret service einen
unangekündigten ausflug zu seinen
anhängern vor dem krankenhaus und
trotzdem bleiben mehr fragen als
antworten
wie geht es ihm wirklich wann ist der
präsident erkrankt wer ist noch
infiziert was sind die politischen
folgen und welche informationen sind
verlässlich
am freitag dem morgen des 2 oktober
kennen die internationalen medien nur
ein thema us präsident und die first
lady melania wurden positiv auf corona
getestet der präsident ist in quarantäne
im weißen haus wahrscheinlich wurde er
von einer engen mitarbeiterin angesteckt
us-präsident trump hat eine
wahlkampfveranstaltung in florida am
heutigen abend abgesagt nachdem er
positiv auf das corona virus getestet
wurde
zu diesem zeitpunkt ist noch völlig
unklar ob trump bereits symptome hat wo
er sich angesteckt hat und welche
mitarbeiter sich ebenfalls infiziert
haben
wir haben natürlich die engsten
mitarbeiter getestet und ich kann ihnen
sagen dass müsste kuscheln ist das
casino und ich selbst getestet wurden
wir haben negative ergebnisse bekommen
gleichzeitig erwarte ich dass sich das
virus weiter verbreitet und andere
mitarbeiter im weißen haus sicherlich
positive ergebnisse haben werden
warum tragen sie keine maske
also ich würde natürlich getestet und
wir stehen hoffentlich mehr als zwei
meter voneinander entfernt und falls es
sorgen über unseren umgang damit gibt
wir halten uns an die regeln in palm
springs kalifornien verteilt giuliana
bohrloch unterdessen wie so oft in den
letzten wochen ihre selbstgemachten
trump caps und trump masten auf der
straße ich hatte so eine angst als ich
die nachricht am frühen morgen auf mein
telefon bekommen habe und jetzt spreche
ich hier mit so vielen menschen und hier
mit man freunden und jeder sendet seine
gedanken und seine kraft an melania und
an trump sie hat den glauben an die
stärke ihres präsidenten nicht verloren
seine unterstützer sagt sie müssen jetzt
noch enger zusammen halten sind sie
einen trump freund ja dann dürfen sie
sich jetzt eine maske aussuchen die
hämischen kommentare und die zweifel die
über trumps infektion pausieren können
sie hier in palm springs nicht nach
warum sollte er vorgeben cupid zu haben
das macht keinen sinn
ich denke es zeigt doch nur dass er ein
normaler mensch ist wie jeder andere
auch
also wenn leute das sagen dann ist das
weil sie trump nicht unterstützen
in dem alter muss man sich natürlich
sorgen machen ich bin besorgt
giuliana zeigt stolz ihre t shirts mit
dem autogramm dass sie von ihrem
präsidenten bekommen hat wenn die
menschen gegen ihn sind ich bin es nicht
ich glaube an ihn jeden tag jede sekunde
und dann macht sich juliana auf den weg
um donald trump im wahlkampf endspurt so
gut sie kann zu unterstützen
vor dem weissen haus tritt kelly
mcinerney die pressesprecherin des
präsidenten am mittag vor die kameras
von trump selbst gibt es freitagmittag
immer noch keine neuigkeiten
ich werde keine details bekanntgeben er
hatte milde symptome aber er arbeitet
hart wir müssen ihn sogar ein wenig
bremsen
er hat mit den senatoren mccall und
graham telefoniert mit stabschef meadows
hat der notfall bestimmungen für
einzelne staaten und wirtschafts anreize
besprochen
erarbeitet hat trotz milder symptome und
der republikanische senator mitch
mcconnell gibt sich gleich danach alle
mühe den stabilen zustand des
präsidenten zu bestätigen
heute morgen habe ich mit dem
präsidenten telefoniert er war guter
dinge aber natürlich wie sie sich
vorstellen können ist er nicht glücklich
im weißen haus eingeschlossen zu sein
ausgerechnet donald trump der über
monate die pandemie verharmlost und der
schutzmaßnahmen wie masken oder social
distance in klein geredet hat hat sich
jetzt mit dem virus infiziert
ich denke masken zu tragen wenn ich
präsidenten treffe premierminister
diktatoren könige königinnen ich weiß
nicht ich sehe das für mich selbst nicht
die wirtschaft hoch war
bloß kein lockdown immer wieder lobt
sich trump vor seinen anhängern selbst
für seinen politischen kurs alles unter
kontrolle die experten sind cool sie
haben es gut gemacht alles unter
kontrolle
der erfolg bringt uns zusammen aber dann
wurden wir von der plage aus china
getroffen und jetzt müssen wir wieder
von vorne anfangen
[Musik]
in washington bezweifeln viele
amerikaner innen dass der präsident
durch seine eigene erkrankung geläutert
wird
monatelang hat trump die eigene agenda
vor die effektive bekämpfung der
pandemie gestellt ich hoffe einfach es
wird ihm helfen cupid etwas ernster zu
nehmen und es nicht kleinzureden
ich bin aber nicht zu optimistisch dass
er es nicht herunterspielen wird egal ob
er melde oder stärkere symptome hat wir
wünschen dem präsidenten nichts
schlechtes aber es ist keine
überraschung dass es in diese richtung
geht wir hoffen einfach dass es seine
politische linie verändern wird und dass
er manche aktivitäten zurückfahren wird
wie die wahlkampfauftritte wo er im
grunde als rattenfänger agiert und seine
sicht verbreitet die anzahl der toten
ist so unglaublich tragisch über 200.000
in diesem land und ich möchte nicht dass
die zahl um einen einzigen fall steigt
aber ich glaube es sagt viel aus dass
der anführer unseres landes jetzt selbst
erkrankt ist für ihn ging es die ganze
zeit nicht um die menschen oder das
beste für die gesellschaft oder die
gesundheit der gesellschaft es ging ihm
nur um die auswirkungen auf seine
wiederwahl
mehr als 200.000 tote mehr als sieben
millionen infizierte kein land ist
schlimmer von der pandemie betroffen als
die usa und das krisen management und
die irreführenden äußerungen des
präsidenten haben ihren teil dazu
beigetragen
in einer studie macht die cornell
universität donald trump persönlich für
38 prozent aller falschinformationen
über die pandemie verantwortlich die
grippe tötet in unserem land zwischen
25.000 und 69.000 menschen pro jahr
das hat mich schockiert und wir haben
bislang 15 fällen und dann gibt es ja
diese desinfektionsmittel die das virus
in einer minute ausschalten
gibt es eine möglichkeit etwas zu machen
wie eine injektion beinahe wie ein durch
reinigen
viele ärzte glauben es ist sehr
erfolgreich das hydrox ii chloroquin
zusammen mit zink und vielleicht mit
zitrone ziehen
jetzt wo der präsident mit dem virus
infiziert ist rückt die frage in den
mittelpunkt wie corona das weiße haus
erreichen konnte und wen donald trump
selbst angesteckt haben könnte in dieser
situation ist es wichtig die
kontaktpersonen zu finden und das ist
intensiver arbeit wenn man bedenkt wie
viele menschen der präsident trifft das
ärzte team des präsidenten sollte eng
zusammenarbeiten mit gesundheitsämter
und sollte diese unterstützen dass die
kontaktpersonen schnell gefunden werden
ist jetzt entscheidend um so kritischer
werden jetzt die jüngsten termine trumps
unter die lupe genommen
am samstag den 26 september stellt er im
rosengarten des weißen hauses amy
kunibert als seine nominierte für den
freien richterposten am supreme court
vor mindestens sieben personen die sich
zum großteil ohne masken und dicht
beieinander aufhielten wurden bislang
positiv getestet darunter seine
ehemalige chefberaterin kelly ann conway
die senatorin mike leigh und tom thill
ist
wann genau sich der präsident mit dem
virus angesteckt hat ist weiterhin
unklar
am dienstag den 29 september trifft
trump in ohio beim ersten tv-duell auf
seinen herausforderer joe biden den er
auf die frage warum er keine maske trägt
vor den augen von millionen zuschauern
verspottet ich habe meine maske hier ich
setze sie auf wenn ich glaube dass ich
sie brauche heute zum beispiel wurde
jeder getestet und wir achten auf
abstand und all die regeln aber ich
trage massin wenn ich sie brauche wenn
ich sie brauche trage ich eine maske
aber ich trage die maske nicht wie er
immer wenn man ihn sie trägt eine maske
er könnte 70 meter entfernt stehen und
er würde mit der größten maske
auftauchen die ich je gesehen habe
am tag nach dem tv duell spricht trump
vor tausenden anhängern in toulouse
minnesota und wirft zur begrüßung make
america drake apps ins publikum
[Applaus]
hallo alle zusammen hallo hallo danke in
34 tagen werden wir minnesota gewinnen
wir werden weitermachen und vier weitere
wunderschöne jahre im weißen haus haben
und wir werden mehr erreichen als jeder
andere zuvor im weißen haus
kurz nach der wahlkampfveranstaltung
zeigt hob extremes engste beraterin die
ersten symptome trotzdem fliegen sie
gemeinsam mit der air force one
wenig später wird bekannt dass hicks
infiziert ist trump aber spricht am
selben tag vom baldigen ende der
pandemie
wir sind kurz davor einen impfstoff
herzustellen und zu verteilen noch vor
ende des jahres ich möchte sagen das
ende der pandemie ist in sicht und
nächstes jahr wird eines der größten
jahr in der geschichte unseres landes
seien am donnerstag wenige stunden bevor
trump positiv getestet wird fliegt er zu
einem fundraising event in seinem
eigenen golf club in batmans der new
jersey
obwohl er von hicks positiven test wurst
und traf sich dort mit freunden und
spendern
wir waren zehn zwölf meter entfernt ich
habe viele fragen bekommen ob ich mich
in quarantäne begebe meine antwort ist
warum sollte ich wir werden hier nicht
unsere eigenen regeln aufstellen wir
werden befolgen was wir müssen aber wir
müssen unsere wirtschaft wieder in
schwung bringen
wir müssen den menschen wieder arbeit
geben wir können nicht in lockt downs
aus angst vor dem virus leben
ich bin überzeugt der präsident wird
sich schnell erholen und ich wünsche ihm
gute besserung
die nachricht dass präsident trump im
krankenhaus behandelt wird hat das land
in einen schockzustand versetzt
die herausforderer joe biden und camilla
harris zeigen respekt für ein paar tage
verzichten sie auf kritische kampagnen
ihre genesungswünsche aber versehen sie
gleich mit einem abhält ich will den
präsidenten und die first lady jetzt
nicht angreifen wenn sie mit dem kroner
virus infiziert sind will und ich beten
für ihre schnelle und vollständige
genesung
wir beten für einen impfstoff dass er so
schnell wie möglich kommt aber bis das
passiert müssen wir alle unsere masken
tragen
wir müssen abstand halten wir müssen
alles tun was in unserer macht steht wir
müssen uns an die regeln halten und die
solche zu bekämpfen
trumps wahlkampftour ist bis auf
weiteres abgesagt sie ist der pandemie
die der präsident am liebsten weggeredet
hätte zum opfer gefallen es wird wie ein
wunder eines tages verschwinden
wichtiger noch als die frage ob trump
seine auftritte abhalten kann ist dass
die pandemie wieder in den fokus der
wähler gerückt wird und ihnen wieder
stärker vor augen geführt wird und die
umfragen zeigen dass beiden bei diesem
thema einen vorteil hat vortrag corona
das thema das er im wahlkampf mit allen
mitteln vermeiden wollte überdeckt in
diesen tagen alles es ist offen wem es
am ende nutzen wird jetzt richten sich
alle augen auf den infizierten
präsidenten